[Music]
how the hell do you tolerate that kind
of pain you'd suck it up and play I play
games with the flu I play games with 102
degree fever you got to be on man we
were playing against the Lakers Tom I'm
going to get there at 3:00 who do I see
I see Kobe Bryant already working out so
I worked out for a good hour hour and a
half and when I came off after I was
done I sat down and of course I still
heard the ball bouncing I look down I'm
like this guy's this guy's still working
out he was working out like it looks
like he was in a dead sweat when I got
here and he's still going he's doing
like game moves cuz I'm like I want to
see how long this goes I sit out there
and watch that game he drops 40 on us
and after the game is over I'm like I I
have to ask this guy I I have to
understand so after the game is I'm like
hey Co like why why were you in a gym
for so long he's like cuz I saw you come
in and I I wanted you to know that it
doesn't matter how hard you work that
I'm willing to work harder than you